ρόπος οποίος για να σταματίζειτουν τη φωνή της σκέψι του την ουσία που δουλαλή σε
αχριστός τι ανάξειωσίς προβληματικώς καταφεύγει σες κληρού εφυσμούς να ιοξω τηνύκτα ποιο πιον που κάνει
ουβίσκει και θα με καταλάβουν οι άλλοη ότι με πρόβληματικώς ολεβελρι ανοεθισμένος ο καπνιστείς που
δουλεύπιουν λημέρα και τα λπά και ταλυπά που γνα σταματήσω καιο πάει και ο πάει
το δέκαο θεώς το εμια τώρα είναι άνθρωπος που έχε καταφέρει να πεθάνει πριν πεθάνει
και όχε καταλάβει ότι δεν επαρχικείο θάναδος να πεθανει φυσικά να πεθάνει τούτη στορία μέσα
σότο μιαλών του που του μιλάουν λημέρα που πορπο αλλά τος ο λαος δι να
προχωρήσει προς τά πρι ενεβει επίπεδα να φύ που το δύο τρί αι πα τοτές
τς αραπέτε να βρίσκει η γυναίτειως να παντεύκετετε ς αραβέτε να κάμυνει παρά μεταστ σαραβένετε
και ψηρίζει ανθρώπου στε αραβένετε και πτούτον το πρόβλημα της κύρου και εγ για ότων
το πράμα για να γίνει των το πράγμα πρέπει αμέσως εκτές να ξεκινήσει να γίνει
μελέετι ωστή σοβαρύ να τούν ιδική ου τον σωτερικόν πυ υπάρχουν ου α τους ξεστύσω
τηα τα βέντε άτομα και να ξεκινήσουμε μες τα δημοτικά σχολία αμέσως όπό και που
τον επτιαγωρίων το μάθημα της συνεσθηματικής και πνευματικής παιδία να μάθυμ τα μορά τι σημαίοι
φόβος τι σημαίνει ντροπήτμοτων το πράγμα δα είνα μορών τώρα ντρέπετε και οπίδεν ήξέρει να
που των το πράμα διλαδή νιώσει παράξενα και τι κα για ναχωστεί πάχει χαπνίζει πινι
λκόν κάι ιακαταλπρίπρέπει να μάθουν οη μιί τι ενιεντούτων το πράγμα που νιώθουν μέσα τους
ουτόσω τε πλέον ναλλάξει ναεγικαι να σου πω και κάτι χωρίς τον το πράμα που
ολέο τώρα δενέν έχεισοτηρία τού τη χώρα α μέωθα μέιικύπρος θελει έργα αιλίσουμε ναθέλει να
να λύσουν α ενα λσουμε το κύπριακό να κάνουμε μια χώρα που να ζούμενούλι αγαπημένοι
μέσ μια χρα είναι πάνω βουλέ αι κάτω δουλέ όπου όκαι τούτο λλα τα πράγματα
πουαλούσει θενα σου κόκννα κλείσουμε επιδν ένη ώρα θα ανακλίσουμε επειδή πεοεσύ που δναρχήτης υσήκ